use my time to be free
well Nozick's seemingly announces he's
gay on world Pride Day the old town road
rapper tweeted along with the lyric
video to a song closure asking fans to
listen closely to it tweeting in part
some of y'all already know some of y'all
don't care
some of y'all not gonna [ __ ] with me no
more but before this month ends I want
y'all to listen closely to closure he
capped it off with three emojis
including a rainbow if there were any
doubts about the meaning behind his
tweet the rapper seems to have cleared
them up for us tweeting again
dead-ass thought i made it obvious along
with his album artwork which features a
rainbow he zoomed in on
the news comes on the last day of Pride
Month and fans are of course standing
lil nas one Twitter user wrote LGBT King
we love and support you no matter what
while another called the 20 year old
rapper brave
[Music]
it's been a big month for the rapper who
delivered a show-stopping performance at
the Beatty Awards alongside Billy Ray
Cyrus singing their smash hit old town
road that was the most amazing thing
I've ever experienced in my life
[Music]